all right let's go to this from the
daily mail it says
a hero wisconsin mother of two died
eight days after suffering suffering
severe injuries when she saved her
four-year-old son from being brutally
attacked by the family's pitbull
heather pingle 35 for bowler suffered
kidney failure lung damage and both of
her arms had to be amputated after the
pit bull viciously attacked her and her
son
she was rushed to the
aspiris hospital where she died of her
injuries on december 16th
damian received uh
70 stitches to his leg and his back and
is back home recovering
that's her son
damian
so she had both her arms amputated then
eventually she died
yeah i bring this case up because it's a
horrible case but also
uh
yet again i think it emphasizes that
it's uh it's simply crazy to
allow these these animals to be
owned
you know in in our neighborhoods
this kind of thing it happens every
single year
it is not all that rare
pit bulls are very dangerous animals
they're bred to be dangerous
they are uniquely dangerous
not every dog breed is equal in that
sense
some dog breeds are more dangerous pit
bulls are the most dangerous
because they are bred to be aggressive
they're bred to be fighting dogs
they're built like machines
and you could say all you want did i
have a pit bull and he's so cute and i
put funny hats on him and the kids he
would never hurt anybody no he's a he's
an animal
okay
and if he has a bad day or if something
snaps or something triggers
you know someone does something innocent
but that triggers an instinctive
reaction in the animal he's going to
become he's going to become a
a death machine
mauling children killing women this
happens every single year
in fact the website ban pitbulls.org
which i think they put their biases
right there in the url but it's but even
so the information is good
it says um
pit bull tax in the u.s
rose 700 and so this this information is
a little bit old
but since 2014
it says pitbull attacks in the us rose
773 percent
between 2007 and 2014.
in the 10-year period from 2005 to 2014
pit bulls killed 200 americans and
accounted for 62 percent
of the 326 total recorded deaths by dog
bites
um
and uh
and then it goes on with more statistics
but you you can look up yourself but
vast majority of maulings happen by
pitbulls
now if you want to look at dog bites in
general including just like a nip on the
hand pit bulls might not be at the top
there probably like a poodle would be at
the top but poodles poodles aren't
killing anybody
so
severe maulings pit bulls by far away
responsible for most of them
um they killed 200 people in the span of
seven years now
yeah you could say well you know many
more people die of car accidents every
year so on and so forth but
this we're talking to hundreds of people
mauled to death by animals
by animals that we allow into our
communities
why
i so i know what the argument is for not
allowing pit bulls to ban pit bulls
the argument is that these can be very
very dangerous animals uniquely
dangerous and they kill hundreds of
people and they maul thousands of people
and um and young kids get their faces
ripped off and so
that's why we should not allow pit bulls
that's the argument for banning them
what is exactly is the argument for
allowing them
the argument is they're cute i like them
that's really the whole argument that's
just
that is not an argument
this pit bulls are not this is this is
not uh we talk about the right to bear
arms because i know that's another thing
pit bull apologists will often make this
comparison oh well what you're doing
this is just what the uh what the gun
control crowd does with guns
yeah you have a constitutional right to
bear arms
there's no constitutional right to bear
pit bulls
football is an animal
and there are all kinds of animals that
you're not allowed to bring into
neighborhoods and i would think that
most of us would agree with most of
those you can't bring a lion into most
communities will not allow you
to just own a lion and have it hanging
around in the backyard
is that an infringement of your
constitutional rights
no and why don't we allow lions well
because
uh yeah i mean
there are probably cases of people
having domesticated lions and not
getting mauled by them but they are
uniquely dangerous these are wild
animals
it presents a threat to the community
and there's just no good reason to do it
so your desire to have a lion does not
outweigh
the desire of your neighbor
to not have his child's face bitten off
back to music if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up and share
it with all your friends